I was wondering what your thoughts are
on meditation and if you practice it
yourself?
Well,
that's a good question.
I think I practiced it a lot and look,
when I listened to someone,
or even when I listened to myself,
but let's say when I listened to someone
in my clinical practice,
I think I do it in a meditative way in
that I sit and listen and I wait for
thoughts to appear rather than
voluntarily thinking.
So I clear my mind.
I try to keep my agenda's off the table,
my agendas,
whatever they are,
except that I want the best for my
client in this hour and the best say by
their definition.
And mine jointly decided because that's
all part of discussion.
And then I listened very carefully and I
wait for the reactions that occur within
me and then I share them.
And I think that's a meditative
exercise.
I think it's different than voluntary
thinking.
It's like,
you know,
there's a statement in the new testament
that says a knock and the door will
open,
ask and you will receive.
Now
that's a meditative,
that's a,
that's a call to a meditative mode of
existence.
It's like,
well,
often what I do,
for example,
if I want to solve a problem is I,
if I have a problem with my own behavior
or maybe I'm having problems in my
family is all go sit on a badge or a
chair and they'll think,
okay,
I would like an answer to this.
I would like to know what the answer to
this.
And I'm willing to accept whatever
answer is appropriate.
And cause usually you get an answer that
you don't like.
Right?
If it's a real answer,
it's not something that you're going to
be all that happy about and then
magically so to speak and answer
appears.
And I think that's a meditative practice
and
the meditative practices part to clear
your mind of your proximal concerns and
to concentrate more deeply on what might
be regarded as eternally true and to
open yourself up for a revelation in
relationship to what is eternally true.
And I found that incredibly effective.
And I think that you can live like that.
Um,
you just have to abandon your proximal
pursuits.
Now in my new book,
again I wrote a chapter about that
called do what is meaningful and what
not,
what is expedient and it's a bit of a
meditation on the sermon on the mount I
would say because the essential message
in the sermon on the Mount,
which is the foundational document of
Western civilization as far as I'm
concerned,
essentially,
is that you should orient yourself
ultimately towards the highest good that
you can conceive.
And I've tried to formulate that and I
mentioned that earlier in this Q and a
that the highest good that you can
conceive it should be something like
what would be good for you now and good
for you tomorrow and next week and next
month and next year.
So good for you and all the future use
that might exist.
And also at the same time,
good for your family and good for the
community,
you know,
conceptualized narrowly and broadly and
good now for your family and the
community and then also into the future.
So it's something like that.
It's,
it's a balance of goods that stretches
across time and you have to decide if
that's what you really want.
And my sense would be you haven't got
anything better to aim at and that you
should aim at.
The best thing that you can aim at for a
whole bunch of reasons.
One is if you don't aim at something,
you're certainly not going to attain it.
And if you're going to aim at something,
why not aim for the best thing that you
can think of?
And if you do aim for the best thing
that you can think of and you make any
progress whatsoever,
it's extremely exciting.
And if you do aim for the best thing you
can think of and you make some progress,
then it's very life affirming and
validating and that sort of quells your
anxiety and your existential pain.
And so he get yourself properly
oriented.
And the sermon on the mount basically
suggest that you do that by orienting
yourself towards God.
And for the psychological purposes,
we could conceptualize God as the
highest good that you can conceive of.
And then you concentrate on the day.
And so you can get up in the morning and
you can think,
well,
I want the best possible thing to
happen.
And so what is it that I should do to
serve that?
And if you ask that genuinely,
and that's in a meditative way,
I will say you get an answer to that
right away.
Now,
the problem is,
is that it's usually an answer that
involves some kind of sacrifice.
It means that instead of doing what you
would like to do impulsively right now,
you're more likely to have to go do
something.
You know that you've been avoiding.
And that's difficult.
But if you do that,
then you'll have some,
you know,
you can also leave in your day with some
pleasure,
uh,
to reward yourself for doing something
difficult.
But if you,
if you live that way,
then I think that your,
your house stays clean in,
your family stays organized and the
state doesn't rock and all that,
and all that's extremely,
extremely good.
So.